Shire at the time he was a guy that you
know when we did Fury together you know
that was such a wild experience yeah he
was this guy who came in he like pulled
his tooth out because he thought his
character shouldn't have a tooth you
know he like cut his his face you know
he didn't shower for eight months and at
first when I met him I was like this
guy's just [__] he's just loud you
know he's just he's he's he's he's
wearing his process on his sleeve
showing everybody how hard he's working
but what I found you know after the
eight months of working with him was
somebody who you know and this is it's
just my own and he he is every bit this
thing is every bit as vital to him as it
was with me I found a real partner I
found a real kindred spirit I found that
he was so [__] cute he was he was
willing to risk it all for for this for
the work and I I walked away with like
an enormous amount of respect for him
and love for him I I would say I think
he's the best actor I've ever worked
with